plateau miss grave du 30 janvier place
le rapport adamo a réussi à remplir
virtuellement cette fois la capacité du
club soda pour le lancement de son
nouvel album tout virtuellement car son
lancement a eu lieu sur instagram et
près de 7000 internautes y ont assisté
jeudi aux façons nouvelles réalités
nouvelles nouvelle dynamique peut de
plus en plus présente
je pense que la pandémie sont poussés à
à utiliser ce qu'on avait déjà au final
très actif sur les réseaux sociaux
adamo conclut 233 milles abonnés sur
instagram le lancement en ligne de son
album s'est donc imposé comme une
alternative tout indique nick car les
lancements l'isis qui sont des
célébrations très importante dans la
carrière d'un artiste je pense que ça
prend quand même des points de rencontre
ça prend des moments sur lesquels faire
de la promo des moments pour attirer
l'attention
je pense pas que les médiums mort
d'autant dans cette attention l'homme
mais au moins ça peut permettre un point
de rencontre avec les fans pour annoncer
qu'il y ait quelque chose de nouveau de
majeur qui vient faire un alinéa dans ta
carrière la chanteuse catherine major
s'est elle aussi tournés vers internet
pour son lancement
[Musique]
après si j'étais dans un état second
d'abord c'était très surréaliste de
faire un truc comme ça à la maison dans
mon activité j'ai peur de 8 ans à mi
chemin entre le concert et l'émission de
télé le lancement mélanger prestations
directes capsules vidéo et entrevues
plus de 600 personnes ont déboursé 10 $
pour assister à l'événement virtuel
c'est pas de payer du dollar je pense
qu'il dérange les gens c'est ce que les
gens sont pas habitués de ne prendre un
rendez vous pour vous ce vendredi 17h
puis d'être sûr d'être là d'acheter
leurs places à l'avance s'est pas encore
dans notre éducation puis ça va
faut que ça le devienne éventuellement
et même lorsque les salles seront
rouvertes
cette manière innovante de rejoindre le
public pourrait bien rester grâce aux
méthodes de diffusion live qu'on est en
train de développer en ce moment et
grâce aux nouvelles habitudes que les
gens ont l consommer la musique live
tard discussion internet
tout d'un coup ça ouvre des possibilités
de décentralisation tous ne deviendront
pas juste à montréal s'est lentement
virtuels peuvent être plus populaire et
moins coûteux qu'un lancement
traditionnels est-ce qu'on assiste à une
mini révolution dans l'industrie de la
musique
peut-être ici n'est bien alexandre
charti radio canada montréal